this week on brian ross investigates
vigilante justice or injustice a
question raised by the trials of kyle
rittenhouse and the three men accused of
killing a mount arbory and now this
young woman accused of chasing down and
killing a hit-and-run driver from a
minor traffic accident
her lawyer claims she had the right to
make a citizen's arrest
she sees herself as a good samaritan
trying to assist in the apprehension of
a perpetrator from a hit and run the
family of a man killed says she is a
murderer this is the person who wanted
to be the law who took things in her own
manners and took a black life and there
are consequences for that now calls to
strike the laws in every state that
allow citizens arrests a concept that
dates back to medieval times
ordinary citizens should not have the
power to take the law into their own
hands what we see far too often is
use of force and abuse of force
so you would recommend these laws
essentially be abolished across the
country
absolutely yes
that their time has passed
plus this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
in 2021 the idea of making predictions
for 2024
is folly and by the way with all due
respect that sounds like a cop-out
from the law and crime trial network
this is dragon rost investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague here at law and
crime rhonda schwartz and ronda we begin
with the question of vigilante justice
or injustice a question raised by the
trial of kyle rittenhouse in wisconsin
and the three men in georgia accused of
killing a young jogger there it's not
well known but almost every state in
this country allows what are called
citizens arrests empowering individuals
to act as if they were the police a
concept that dates back to medieval
times yet remains valid to this day
rhonda
that's right brian and it's being used
as a defense in cases all around the
country including one that's unfolding
now also in georgia a young woman chased
after a man involved in a minor hidden
accident traffic accident stopped him
and shot him dead
and now this case is raising great
scrutiny as a test of the citizens
arrest laws
hannah payne 21 years old accused of
exacting vigilante justice murdering a
62 62-year-old man named kenneth herring
after she saw him driving away from the
scene of a traffic wreck in clayton
county on may 7 payne's voice heard on a
9-1-1 recording according to a detective
screaming at kenneth haring just before
police say she shot him i know he was
having a diabetic episode because he
didn't just run off the scene i knew he
was trying to get to the hospital i was
still trying to figure why she's trying
to actually
follow him all the way block him in and
kill him officers say payne saw herring
take off from the crime scene so she
followed him in her vehicle trying to
intercede since the subject left the
scene she cut in front of his vehicle
forcing him to stop an altercation then
ensued between the two of them and
during the altercation mr herring was
shot and killed she's using deadly force
judge she wasn't faced with deadly force
he has nothing
and then she shoots him
and we're joined now by the lawyer for
hannah payne matt tucker mr tucker thank
you for being here would you call this
vigilante justice or vigilante injustice
i would say vigilante injustice more
because
she was a young girl she was following
the directives of the department of
corrections officer on the scene she's
following the directive of 9-1-1
she does have members of her family that
are close to law enforcement but they
did tell her don't follow they did tell
her don't follow they said it's our
policy
not to follow but go get the tag can you
get the tag go get the tag okay now we
actually do not want you to chase them
we just want
you to be safe what kind of vehicles
get out of the road get out the road
hurry up hurry up
so she followed the directives from that
um
after getting the tag that's when they
stated all right you need to come back
to the scene of the accident
and she's like
ma'am we've he's already college one she
said you both need to come back to the
scene of the accident and that's when
she stopped him that's when she made
sure that he wasn't going to cause
another accident and you're now set to
go to trial sometime next year
i believe it's going to be in january
i'm going to go ahead and file a motion
and immunity motion stating that she had
the authority to do what she did
um it's still
it's still a question of fact
and we are going to hope that the jury's
gonna find it in our favor that she
never pulled the trigger with intent to
shoot him they were fighting over the
gun his hands were on top of the gun
twisting it back towards her and the gun
went off
she immediately picked up the phone and
said oh my god he just shot himself with
my pistol
[Music]
does she see herself as a vigilante she
sees herself as a good samaritan
trying to assist in the apprehension of
a perpetrator from a hit and run
of course she was not the police does
she tell you that she regrets following
mr herring she says she has nightmares
about that the whole the whole time her
life has changed
does she regret following him trying to
essentially
conduct a citizen's arrest
it's hard to say regret because she was
doing the right thing in her mind she
was doing the right thing she felt she
was doing the right thing and she was
helping the police
um
she regrets that day ever happened and
then she was there when the accident
occurred
but to regret doing something she
thought was helping the community i i
don't
that would be a question for her but
from the indications i get
she felt she was doing the right thing
and that had it not
escalated to what it was based on his
actions she would have been able to get
him to go back to the scene and help and
help the community
have an individual
be accountable for his actions
matt tucker thank you so much for
joining us we'll hear more from you when
you go to trial next year yes sir thank
you so much i appreciate you giving us
the opportunity to allow hannah to tell
her side of the story
hannah payne has pleaded not guilty to
the charges against her and for now as
tucker said the trial is set to be in
january she's currently free on 100 000
bail and the fact that she is free has
outraged the family of kenneth herring
who say she is not the good samaritan
she claims to be
and we're joined now by sir major a
spokesman for the family of kenneth
herring mr major thank you for being
with us tonight the lawyers for hannah
payne say that she acted in as a citizen
making a citizen's arrest what do you
say to that
i call that garbage
miss hannah payne acted as a
villain that day she acted as a
the female version of george zimmerman
if you ask me
she had no legal authority in fact law
enforcement and radio dispatchers told
miss payne not to chase or pursue and
not to engage
their hearing she chose to do what she
wanted to do fatally taking his life
this all could have been avoided um mr
herring was having a medical emergency
which is why he disobeyed traffic laws
uh he was incapacitated and ms payne
took this as uh you know she wanted to
stop this guy and she wanted to serve
her own form of justice and she took his
life
she says when she stopped mr herring and
approached him he tried to grab the gun
and that's why the gun went off and he
was shot
well certainly uh we do know that uh she
did stick a gun in his face she did
assault him uh and and physically it's
all too uh and if i'm incapacitated next
you know i wake up and i see a gun in my
face there may be a struggle as well uh
this is
a natural reaction for anyone who sees a
gun in their face uh to defend
themselves and to get that person away
from off of them um miss hannah payne
was wearing a jacket that uh was
highlighted in the case that said badass
we know for a fact that mr payne just
recently got her gun license and we know
because when i got my gun license i was
ready to go to the to gun range i was
ready to pull the trigger to practice
and um
i think that miss payne was just eager
to pull that trigger
and when she says that she thinks of
herself as a good samaritan
what do you make of that
well there are a lot of good samaritans
sitting in prison right so
this is a person who disobeyed the law
this is the person who wanted to be the
law who took things in her own manners
and took a black life and there are
consequences for that
and do you think it was a racially
tinged uh incident
absolutely i believe that if this had
been a white driver i don't think that
she would have pursued him in the
beginning i believe had it been a white
driver um
maybe this story wouldn't be what it is
today
she says she has no regrets according to
her lawyer about what happened she
regrets what happened in the end but no
regrets in chasing down mr herring so
what she just uh inadvertently told the
court and told the american people is
that this will happen again and that
america cannot stand by the watch
and for the family what would be total
justice
total justice would be uh ms ms hannah
payne being fully prosecuted uh with
with no leniency uh we can't bring back
kenneth here uh and the other thing is
that we want uh his family to be made
whole again whatever that looks like
all right well sir major thank you so
much for joining us a spokesman for the
family of kenneth hair thank you so much
appreciate it
coming up next what you may not know
about who can make a citizen's arrest in
this country and the laws that make it
possible you're watching brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galil gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
and we're joined now by professor ivor
robbins a professor of law at the
american university school of law who
specializes in written a lot about
vigilante justice or what he calls
vigilante injustice professor thank you
for joining us tonight
thank you for having me brian
this notion that there are citizens
arrest and that is legally possible
throughout the country this is a concept
that began in medieval times yet it
continues
it began in medieval times
basically it was a directive of the king
because there was no organized police
force
when the king put out an order to the
constables the constables would call the
citizenry to say it is your duty to
arrest a particular individual
or if the individual
was moving from county to county it was
the citizens responsibility to follow
the individual until that individual
could be delivered to the sheriff
and yet that concept endures in this
country in the 21st century
not only does it endure but every state
united states has citizens arrest
whether by a judicial decree or by
statute
every jurisdiction has it they don't
often use it
but from time to time as we see in a
couple of cases in georgia
it makes the headlines and in very
important ways
we're seeing a spate of so-called uh
vigilante justice or as you have called
it a vigilante injustice do these laws
need to be abolished or changed
in most instances i would think they
need to be severely severely curtailed
ordinary citizens should not have the
power to take the law into their own
hands what we see far too often is
use of force and abuse of force
are there situations in which citizens
arrests
make some sense
yes if a police officer
a trained police officer is outside of
his or her jurisdiction in some other
jurisdiction and witnesses a crime it
makes sense for that individual to
effect a citizen's arrest or a
shopkeeper suspecting someone of
shoplifting
it makes sense if the person has been
trained to affect a citizen's arrest but
not use force
but beyond that it seems to me these
laws ought to be abolished this is
a a doctrine whose time should have
passed
not just years ago but probably
centuries ago
and yet we see it uh used by all sorts
of groups across the country from
so-called neighborhood patrols to
efforts to arrest public officials
we do see it and and that's where we
also see abuses uh it makes no sense for
an ordinary individual to go up to
someone whom he or she suspects of
having committed a crime
and say
i'm going to kill you i'm going to shoot
you i'm going to arrest you
bad things can happen
both to the individual who is arrested
and to the arrest or
when i say bad things can happen i mean
serious injury or death
and if we're not talking at that level
of seriousness the person can be charged
with a crime or can be sued in civil
court for monetary damages uh for for
false arrests
and so for instance the uh plot to
arrest the governor of michigan other
efforts there was an attack on a law
professor all because of disagreements
over what was being taught uh what are
the most uh sort of telling examples in
your mind of of the abuse of this
citizen's arrest doctrine
well the the most telling examples are
the cases in georgia
but you mentioned the
citizens arrest of a professor in
virginia that happened in 2014 and
that's what got me interested in this
issue i thought if a person can come off
the street
go into a classroom or a class is being
taught go up to the professor
and say uh you're under arrest i'm i'm
executing a citizen's arrest and if you
don't comply i'm going to spread you
with pepper spray and that's exactly
what happened that makes no sense people
should not be taking the law into their
own hands so you see in the hannah payne
case in georgia
where she uh effected a citizen's arrest
on someone who had committed a hit and
run
while driving
she thought that she was allowed to do
it she went up to him and she said i'm
going to shoot you and she shot him in
the chest and killed him was that a
lawful citizen's arrest no
because
she thought that she was getting someone
or arresting someone who had committed a
felony
which is allowed under the old georgia
statute that was in effect at the time
it has since been changed but in fact
and again i guarantee she would not have
known this uh a hit and run in which
there were no injuries in georgia is a
misdemeanor it's not a felony so it was
not a good citizen's arrest
but there are notions of the citizens
arrest doctrine around the country and
people try to invoke it as their defense
when they get caught doing something
they do and it should not be a good
defense
uh and and in fact it turns into a house
of cards because the starting point is
they say i i had the right to commit a
citizen's arrest and then during the
arrest the person i was arresting
attacked me so i used self-defense and i
killed that individual
it's a house of cards because if the
citizens arrest was invalid then the
arrest door is an aggressor and the
aggressor does not have the right to
self-defense
so you would recommend these laws
essentially be abolished across the
country
absolutely yes uh that their time has
passed
all right professor iowa robins from
american university thank you so much
for being with us here tonight thank you
very much for having me
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media see if you agree
with the editors of mediaite and what
they had to say about cnn bombshell
report on the tensions between president
biden and vice president harris you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorite and we're joined by
aide mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media empire and aiden
you've chosen as the winner for tonight
cnn for its bombshell report on the
relationship between vice president
harris and president biden they call it
a rocky relationship that she has with
the white house and they also cite
dysfunction at her office
that's true so there's a new report that
dropped on monday i'm sure uh your
viewers have seen this and it's
basically it's a sprawling cnn report
that uh describes kamala harris as being
sidelined in the white house and not
having been adequately prepared for the
job that she is carrying out um the
report is based on interviews with
nearly three dozen former and current
harris aides administration officials
outside democratic office
operatives and outside advisors and it
painted a picture of a vice president
who's struggling to make strides um as
her approval rating along with joe
biden's dip um the report was uh
conducted by uh edward isaac dovier and
jasmine wright at cnn were two really
brilliant reporters and it prompted some
pushback from white house press
secretary jensacki as well as a number
of other outside advisors to the white
house who say there's really nothing
here there is no controversy
but i think it's suffice to say that
this is based on enough internal sources
within the white house and outside um
that i think we can we can
say that it's pretty legitimate um it's
a really good report and it's making
waves um inside and outside the white
house um so those two reporters and cnn
in general uh we decided to make winner
this week and from what you've seen the
story stands up
yeah i mean the white house hasn't
pointed anything specific in it that
would be wrong um i think it's pretty
typical for the white house to push back
on this kind of story which says that
there's dysfunction and that there's
problems between the president's team
and the vice president's team so it's
pretty predictable for the white house
to push back on it but they haven't
provided any evidence that anything in
the story is false
aside from just casting it as you know
an attack on the vice president um
either calling it uh or suggesting that
it's perhaps sexist or racist to be
focusing on her um of course that's a
little bit silly and there's no evidence
that the cnn report has anything to do
with the vice president's race or gender
right and for a loser this week you've
chosen chris christie the former new
jersey governor for his prickly
relationship with dana bash of cnn when
she tried to ask him about why he was
supporting donald trump
donald trump has made it pretty clear he
wants to run for president again
would you support him
oh look i don't know that he's going to
run
what if he does i'm going to run
no look what if i i've learned i mean
it's not as if it's a big secret that
he's seriously considering it he's
seriously considering it let's see what
happens when he does and let's see who
he is and what he says and how he
conducts himself after everything you've
described that he has done you still
know what i'm saying network what i'm
saying to you is
that i'm not going to sit here in
2021 and pre-judge all this
in 2021 the idea of making predictions
for 2024
is folly and by the way with all due
respect that sounds like a cop-out
a cop-out aidan
that's right so chris christie has
always walked to this very strange tight
rope he's really close with president
donald trump uh the former president he
was on his campaign he was tapped uh by
donald trump to be his chief of staff
ultimately that fell through reportedly
due to tensions between chris christie
and jared kushner uh chris christie
voted for trump twice once in 2016 again
in 2020 um but he's also criticized
trump publicly uh and pretty
relentlessly over the years and in the
new book uh for which this interview uh
was being held
that chris christie put out about how to
save the republican party uh christopher
actually is pretty harsh on trump he
says that uh when chris christie uh got
coveted and was hospitalized for seven
days with covet it was after debate prep
that he had held with donald trump
donald trump also got covered shortly
after that debate prep and he said that
when trump called him in the hospital uh
he didn't really care about how chris
christie was doing he cared more about
whether chris christie would blame him
for getting covet um so he's walking
this strange type rope where he
criticizes donald trump but then still
says that he might vote for him in 2024
which is sort of an odd position to be
in uh and one that he's getting a decent
amount of criticism for that's the kind
of position that all republicans are
going to have to do a dance about right
it's and it's this bizarre tightrope you
know do you criticize trump for the
january 6 insurrection but also say that
you might vote for him in 2024 so it's
not to alienate his base um it puts him
in a very odd position and chris
christie hasn't done a great job of
balancing that all right aidan thank you
so much that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you
again here next week
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
you